[Music]
welcome back to off the record where
we're talking about whatever we want
frankie today aka cholo fit cholo
[Laughter]
so we were talking about uh we're
talking about uh
covet [ __ ] how has uh how's your time
during the pandemic been like
oh man especially this stand-up comedian
yeah it was crazy in the beginning it
was funny because we were in
we were in buffalo new york when the
[ __ ] started hearing when they were
talking about shutting [ __ ] down oh you
weren't home
no we were on the road and we're doing
like meet and greets we're doing we're
like definitely exposed you know
whatever the [ __ ] we had to go to jfk to
try to get a flight home and like they
were like
about to shut everything down we barely
caught a flight
on time back to l.a and then all of a
sudden it was like everything was shut
down you know
and then i was living by myself so [ __ ]
got lonely as [ __ ] that's for sure
i ordered like a flashlight [ __ ] did you
i should have got one
as a partner in bed just to touch it
yeah just for like emotional support now
did you get the lip one and the [ __ ]
one so you could do that oh [ __ ]
the one with the legs attached to it
that's that's the weirdest [ __ ]
and the uh the the [ __ ] and ass
combination oh yeah
what a great deal great deal was it was
your flashlight a latina or a white girl
or i think it was i think it was
it looks white like a white girl yeah it
could be ambiguous
it's just a little it's just the the
[ __ ] it is whatever you wanted to be
yeah but not yeah yeah it was it was
just shitty not being cause normally
even we're not on the road we're just
hanging out the comedy clubs or
yeah even doing production and videos
and all that and
at first you're like oh it's another
thing because like when you first heard
about sars or bird flu i don't know not
one homie that got started for real
right but then covert i was like all
right it's another one of those things
on the news but then
then homie started getting it and i'm
like oh [ __ ] like this shit's for real
and so yeah yeah that happened but then
when the holidays came that's when it
really hit like both sides of my family
they all got together
my immediate family though like my mom
has lupus and rheumatoid relationships
so we're like all with socially distance
in my car but the rest of my family are
getting together like
we should be chill like now we're being
safe we're just with family like nah
that's where it's happening
and obviously latinos were the biggest
population in california that were
getting hit with the [ __ ]
and sure enough man like over 20 of my
family members after that party
eight over after christmas and new
year's wow and then like eight of them
were hospitalized and like
some of them got [ __ ] up especially
ones that had diabetes and [ __ ] like
that
2020 new years and uh yeah yeah
just this past yeah yeah christmas and
new year's yeah because so that's why i
think it was a new variant
because i don't think the first one was
that crazy because i think i even i got
it we're at the
end of 2019 we're on the road traveling
and then we continue to travel all the
way to march
and all three of us it was me and my
homie two other homies that were on this
tour and we all three of us got sick and
i remember thinking like damn i haven't
had a flu this bad in a long time
but it wasn't until january when all the
shits are coming on the news and we were
like [ __ ] i think that was it
i could have tangled second smell bro
yeah yeah i couldn't taste it i was
coughing it feel like i couldn't breathe
but then yeah yeah and that new [ __ ]
came out and i think that's the one that
[ __ ] people up i had some homies that
were in the hospital that were like my
age and i was like damn
but but yeah yeah it's crazy how many
different strains are because
my wife's family it's your favorite
stream
who gave us the wuhan wagyu strain man
he went to his house [ __ ] watch the
tyson fight he was like cooking some
meat up and then we ate it and all of us
got it dude oh i got coconut 10 people
got it that
from that weekend
[Laughter]
and all ten of us got the fight wasn't
worth it either yeah
oh that tyson's so disappointed oh yeah
that [ __ ]
it was sad homie it was like they were
both on sleeping pills the whole time
yeah oh man like imagine making mike
tyson like not be able to knock somebody
out it's like all right what's the point
there i know there was a stipulation he
can't punch him in the face once the
rules came
out but the build up he's like man the
war got thrown live inside me again
and i was like oh [ __ ] like we're gonna
see some [ __ ] back alive inside me i'm
ready
[Laughter]
yo my wife to this day is like i'm glad
we didn't go to march that day
i was like why because we would have got
covered and we couldn't go to hawaii
did you guys get it back what happened
did you get it bad or was it no it was
like uh
i had a couple days we all had different
symptoms it was a good strength
good strength it was a mild stream and
then on day three it was gone
like i had but y'all had different
symptoms that's the [ __ ] that trips me
out yeah so i
was like oh i had a cough that feels
like oh i like [ __ ] like my ears are
hot
one of our other friends couldn't taste
like using these spicy ass chips
couldn't
taste oh these are those pepper ones
i'll do that to me
that's terrible i just had a stuffy nose
and couldn't taste nothing
same really i had um aches mostly body
aches and then i couldn't taste [ __ ] how
many days was yours
it was like three days like you yeah it
was only a few days and then but the
taste thing though
it was like for a month that it took
to get back to normal yeah it was slow
but it was crazy
even my cousin i got it he's still a
little bit foggy you know what i'm
saying you catch him just kind of like
damn that's so crazy you're like hey oh
yeah
my wife still can't eat certain things
without tasting like latex gloves
what that's a new one sometimes she'll
just
she'll be making something and then i'm
sure it's not the tongue connor she puts
on when she eats your ass
no she'll i'll hear like so damn that
she puts off more t-shirts i'll hear her
cooking
and then i'll hear the silverware drop
and she's like leather gloves or
whatever and i'm like oh my god it
happened again
leather oh it comes like that no it
depends on what she's eating
so she eats onions we've narrowed that
down to onions garlic it triggers that
triggers the latex the good stuff yeah
mommy not lettuce
lettuce has no taste at all really i got
a really dope side effect from it
sometimes dope yeah like a really good
one
crazy nuts my dick's all big
i come pearl i come pearl white now
i start to taste sweet stuff out of
nowhere like my saliva
is sweet it's sweet like candy yeah yeah
and it'll just come out and then it'll
be it'll be like for 30 seconds or
whatever they said coke was a bad food
yeah it's like i'm like what the [ __ ]
tastes like licorice yeah it just
it's weird sour sauce
tastes like ponzu ooh ponzu we believe
that we had i had it twice because
cause twice like you when we when you
december
before covenant 19 december sickest i've
ever been
and then the second time it was [ __ ]
[ __ ] so i believe that i
must have had i must have had something
already in my system so i could deal
with it easier true
but when i did take the test i didn't
have both
the antibodies no but those have been
[ __ ] too right the the
antibody test they said that it's only
forty percent like
false power or some [ __ ] like that yeah
yeah yeah so which is like
the fine point it's crazy it it says it
gets more accurate as more people
take it so it's not like when when these
tests when they come out
they're not like a uh like a straight up
like like a [ __ ] you know like ph
litmus test where it's okay it's indeed
like acid in here
it's your i guess your genetic makeup
compared to the population so it's like
a comparison test
so as more people take it it gets more
and more accurate it's a bigger sample
size
that's the thing yeah yeah but what's
crazy is after exposure i waited over a
week
i i tested like the eighth or ninth day
and then it was negative for both
and then a day or two after that i lost
taste
so that's the weird [ __ ] because the
tests didn't work yeah
and even it depends on the type of test
too right it's like i did
both they barely dab i've gotten like 26
tests
oh [ __ ] cuz from filming and [ __ ] once
production started up yeah they're
testing us every day homie or like
at least once every other day but
there's the ones that barely dab your
nose in the ones that they go [ __ ]
you know they're scratching your brain
and [ __ ]
and it's like well then you know how do
you even i don't know the science behind
that like
if you put it up deeper do you get more
of the [ __ ] snot
i don't get it that's the other part
that doesn't make sense too where it's
like if you got to go
that deep to get a sample why do we
gotta stay six feet away
to be contagious it's like i can't
oh you can oh [ __ ] you're gonna give it
to me wait hold on you have
it though do you [ __ ] have it it's
like what
it's because the thing that's up
apparently the thing that's up in here
that's that's
inhibiting our taste and smell yeah
that's what they're getting up there for
oh yeah yeah but then you could spread
like that makes sense
like this you can spray it if i sneeze
on you that's like getting an eyeball
i don't know none of it makes sense i
kiss you on the lips but that's the
thing about
the fog of war kind of right where
something's happening when it first
landed we're all like holy [ __ ]
like we're seeing videos of people
collapsing in the streets in china
and we're like whoa is that gonna happen
over here like we just didn't know yet
what was gonna happen but those videos
are good the apocalypse
he was doing stand-up he's sitting on a
thing and he's just like immigrants
and then he just passed out oh [ __ ]
carry him on stage cancel the rest of
the weekend
it was that bad yeah and then he was
like got on his talk show he's like i
don't know what i was thinking i just he
thought it was
you know like upstart is a really fast
and easy way
to pay off your debt all online
um you know what's pretty crazy so i
always said this like
ever since i was in debt right and i'm
like it never
made any sense why everyone is like
judging you based off of your credit
core likes credit credit score if
they're loaned to you and
i was like thinking if you need money
because you can't pay off things
yeah and your credit score is like
getting destroyed right
how are you gonna get money to pay for
those things if you don't have a job
where like if you do but it doesn't have
like
it doesn't make any sense it's like you
just go deeper and deeper yeah like how
do you get back on your feet
if you're never on your feet and they're
judging you by your feet right yeah it's
like
how how are you gonna even run if you
can't even pay for the shoes
to run with yeah yeah so i was i was
thinking like if someone can figure out
a lending company that helps and they're
not predatory because there are people
that go
oh you got a bad credit score we'll all
lend you some money
but i'm gonna charge you like uh
50 like a loan shark yeah you know like
there's things out there but it just
screws people over that need help
it's pretty cool though that how upstart
went beyond just the credit score and
judging
if they can lend to you or not like they
go based off income
um your education um all this stuff they
they know that like sometimes people can
pay
and they're really good for it is just
they go through bad
times yeah so or sometimes i don't know
this is like back in the day where you
rent like a video
and you forget to return it because it
got stuck underneath the couch and so
literally
all of your other stuff is good but
because of one stupid account it goes to
collection and it dings you for such a
long time
and now when you're in a crunch you need
money like you said like how the hell do
you get back on your feet when you need
money but no one else will even give you
money so upstart is cool because they
look at
way more than just your credit score so
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments or
get you out of any bad situation go to
upstart.com
off the record to see if they can help
you that's upstart.com
off the record check them out loan
amounts will be determined by your
credit your income and the
other information that are included in
your loan application
there's that one lady i think he's she's
like the doctor fauci of like denmark or
something you guys see where
she passed out yeah she got the vaccine
she's at the podium and she's like
all right so this vaccine you guys don't
want to take it
she take it i don't know but it's just
bad timing for whatever vaccine
that's rough you don't want to take it
it was just so bad but like when you get
the vaccine
they tell you like it was my first shot
i got like last week and they're like
all right
after you get the shot wait your car for
15 minutes and just don't go anywhere
and i was like what
because yeah yeah yeah i mean like [ __ ]
you too now i don't know if i want to
get this shot
and you know it's not that big of a deal
but it's like it's still in your head
you're like playing tricks on yourself
like [ __ ] am i gonna
die in my car how many how often do you
[ __ ] pass out your car that's
not normal and i was like dude i'm fine
bro and i was driving home and i was
like what if i pass out now i was like
freaking out but i was fine
yeah how do they know it's not gonna be
minute 20. yeah yeah exactly
seventeen it's usually like eight while
you're driving it [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah i'll be fall asleep
anyway while i drive what about you what
are we saying
what are we talking about watching
people pass out it's [ __ ] fun so
funny dude when they full
face plank i laugh every time i cannot
laugh
especially like as they're talking and
then they go like out like that's
that's that's a special one that's a
good one like the roller coaster ones
they're
like like this oh they actually and
their hearts are playing like this
do you guys think like once everything
opens up
you would just go for it and be like
[ __ ] yeah
spring break style or would you be like
i'ma just let everybody
test it first
i'm the guy in war who's i've said this
many times who's like yeah yeah yeah
i'll go get all
i'm right behind you dude dude for me
i'm not even in the front line i'm
already behind enemy lines
there you go you're dressed like the
enemy and you're like
[ __ ]
to think about how many veterans that
survived faked
death and we're like complete [ __ ]
but we will never know and i would never
judge them either no i would never
i would too i think about that all the
time they were there when i watched 1917
i was like oh i'd be one of those guys
that just like
pretending to be dead yeah i'd be one of
those saving private ryan like damn
i don't identify with the hero i
identify with the guy that's like you
think your chances of surviving just by
laying there
is higher or you think you're gonna be
blowing up anyways because like the
[ __ ] like in the movies it's just
like the ground just going
yeah one uh one movie i forgot what it
was where like
the other side after the battlefield
settles down
they just take a knife and they start
stabbing and they go to everyone on the
floor
and stab them just in case so mean and
i'm like what the [ __ ] they're
breaking my plans yeah yeah that must
take so long that's just so [ __ ] mean
anymore or whether it explodes like when
like a cannon hits you lay right there
right after it explodes because like the
chances of it hitting there again
probably not that high or i don't know
or i don't know
as i'm saying out loud i'm like oh
that's not a good point why do we even
have war rules if they're going to be
that mean
go with a bayonet jesus i'm like wait
what about the war rules hey look time
out
seems a little uncalled for you like
some some
machine guns can't be used on people
yeah the geneva convention yeah but like
it's not like they're like yeah they're
like they're not going
to do like an airplane there's a guy
with a like a smaller like ar
i think in war there's my bucket no
they're like hey you can't do that
you know you can't do that [ __ ] that's a
foul that's a fact
rules that's the foul i get two free
shots
[Laughter]
you can't do that you can't [ __ ] do
that
in a referee shirt we should have war
referees dude we will
we need them on site for the next one i
know
[ __ ] it for the next one the next one
yeah
next time have you guys been watching
all the crazy conspiracy things
like how world war iii is gonna happen
and all this [ __ ] like because i went
down the rabbit hole during the pandemic
and it's like
this leads to this corona is just
getting us prepared for all that war and
[ __ ]
and i'm like dude that would be the
craziest war with our technology
that we have today we could just have
like robots fight for us
but also we have a lot of people who
don't go
out so it's like can you imagine most of
the people now the gen z and millennials
like trying to fight
dude that would be crazy dude i think
about all the drones that they could use
to
deploy bombs all over cities and scares
of [ __ ] like
wars absolutely yeah because aren't they
having a lot of like less numbers of
people enlisting in like military just
across the board like they just can't
get anybody they're like willing to take
anybody
well do they need that many people and
they got they got drones now well i
don't know
apparently i heard a lot of people like
that are listers that are like
we can't get anybody no no it's not cool
to be like warlike for
the younger generation now yeah like
everyone like hella
you know mother earth lovers
new uh hippie mother i love us i think
so
man peace and love yeah
what does the tiger uh eyes mean tiger
eye bracelets
i don't know you say one love you know
that's all you need though all you need
is like a james bond movie or something
to come out to make everyone go oh yeah
yeah that's right like guns and [ __ ]
kicks ass war kicks ass i forgot
true like espionage and [ __ ] that's when
it's fun for a fast and furious movie
yeah the nine that's why it's it's war
propaganda that's what it is
space wars that's nice i think there's
always they'll always be [ __ ]
that just want that [ __ ] like yeah i
want the smoke
when you meet like real soldiers that
are just like straight killers you just
see it in their eyes man they're like oh
they fully embrace that [ __ ]
i met this one dude in in uh afghanistan
and he was like this skinny ass little
dude from like north carolina or
something
and there was all these big ass buffalos
like around him and then he's like
and he's like i'm the i'm the i'm the
baddest [ __ ] out here his gun
was like a little bit bigger than
everybody else
skinny and small and then i'm like
looking at the buff dudes like oh is he
the better one for her they're like yup
they're talking about being in war with
them and he's just out front just taking
[ __ ] out you know and you guys
just found a shoulder because a little
guy probably huh
something but i'm like asking him about
it he's like oh yeah man i got
nightmares every night or [ __ ]
day he just like fully isn't like he's
like this is me
this is my life that's a trip and i'm
like god damn homie like this shit's
crazy you know
we need you out the front lines bro yeah
please don't join gangs and then join
the military instead
yeah right we need more guys like that
to fight for us
yeah for real but like these war heroes
are read like what they went through to
get like their medal of honor or
whatever
and there's fools that take like three
shots in the face
and they still like uh traverse the
mountain
with the [ __ ] knife in their mouth or
whatever i'm like what the hell some
rambo [ __ ] yeah
one of those stories is insane if i get
if i even hear like
i'm like oh [ __ ]
dude i'm like that on paintball i'm like
that during paintball
my buddy gets hit with the paintball and
i'm like
i'm down too i'm down i'm down i gotta
get out
i find two [ __ ] handguns i put her on
the ground like
i [ __ ] shot myself
i'll probably take take a bullet on the
shoulder that scraped it and i'll
[ __ ] be entitled for a metal honor
what the [ __ ] i was injured in war
[ __ ] give me my discharge right
that's a purple heart do they have do
they have a um
like a razzie of war
where it's like hey dude you you were a
[ __ ] out there
it's like we saw you you dressed like a
woman and you went into a brothel and
you got like
with the
[Laughter]
i know man there's probably mad stories
like that right yeah people don't blame
them
that's the war movie we should all reach
the untold story
yeah fools they get drafted and [ __ ]
they want no part of it but they still
go like
they're doing all that [ __ ] the untold
story because you always hear the story
you were never told
yeah yeah and it's like you see a guy
putting on garter belts and [ __ ]
with lipstick get away create a little
campsite
he had to survive
how many dixie
like whatever it takes to survive i can
see this starting to come together
hell yeah because that's real war if you
think about it not this
like superhero it's just how do you
[ __ ] survive
yeah that's what you're thinking that's
what i feel like 99 percent of all
soldiers probably
think i don't [ __ ] get out of this
situation they do it so cool
our homie don he's uh like a special ops
marine guy he said when he first got
deployed and they went with the super
because uh with the super small unit
because they're special ops
and the first time like they heard they
were under fire
he was like [ __ ] bricks he's like oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] he just here
and he looks over at his like team
leader and this was just like smoking a
cigarette like he has so much ptsd
doesn't even [ __ ] affect him oh yeah
yeah he was like he's just like oh we
just gotta chill a little bit and
they'll return
fire and then dodge like what the [ __ ]
man he's like [ __ ] [ __ ] question all
my every single decision i ever made in
my life
he's on the radio to command already we
need backup over here
and it's just like it's just the goat
herder with the ak-47
we need every [ __ ] thing bring
everything
somebody hands me that phone thing i'm
like oh man
this job sucks this is the worst job in
the whole military because nobody ever
answers you
i've seen this movie too many times we
were on a base in afghanistan one time
and it took on enemy fire in the middle
of the night and they woke us up and
like escorted us to these bunkers
homie i'm gonna [ __ ] myself i'll just
like [ __ ] zip
but they're just like they're shooting
like rpgs and they're not
very accurate so they say like a lot of
them are just shooting and just hoping
to hit something
yeah but it was they were they were
shooting the [ __ ] though and i was just
like what the [ __ ]
rpgs bro that's [ __ ] insane crazy
homie and then we take flights and they
do those tactical landings because it'll
be fools in the mountains to rpgs and
they're doing
or they do the nose diving oh homie
yeah i'm just like all the soldiers
aren't used to it they're just like
laughing at us
i think after you shoulder fire rpg and
you missed like a helicopter
these guys turned into like damn
you